let's say i go to the fruit store today
and they have a sale on guavas
everything is 30
off this is for guavas on
guavas
and it's only today
only
only
today so i say you know what let me go
buy a bunch of guavas so i go and i buy
six guavas so i buy six
guavas
and it ends up when i go to the register
and you know we're assuming no tax for
you know it's a grocery and i live in a
state where they don't tax groceries so
for the six guavas they charge me i get
the 30 off they charge me
12.60
12. and sixty cents so this is the
thirty percent off sale price on six
guavas i go home and then my wife tells
me you know sal can you go get two more
guavas tomorrow i say sure so the next
day i go and i wanna buy two more guavas
so two
guavas
but now the sale is off there's no more
thirty percent that was only that first
day that i bought the six so how much
are those two guavas going to cost me
how much are those two guavas going to
cost at full price
at
full
price
so a good place to start is to think
about how much would those six guavas
cost us at full price this is the sale
price right here this is the sale
price how much would those have cost me
at full price
so let's
do a little bit of algebra here let me
pick a suitable color for the algebra
oh maybe this little gray color so let's
say that x
is equal to the cost
of
six guavas
six guavas
at
full price
so essentially if we take 30 off of this
we should get 12.60 so let's do that so
if we have the full price of six guavas
we're going to take 30 percent off of
that so that's the same thing as
0.30 or i could just write 0.3 i could
ignore that 0 if i like actually let me
write it like this my wife is always
bugging me to write 0s before decimals
so that's the full price of 6 guavas
minus 0.30
times the full price of guavas so i'm
literally just taking 30 percent off of
the full price off of the full price
this is what how we figure out the sale
price this is going to be equal to that
12.60 right there
that's going to be equal to twelve
dollars and sixty i just took thirty
percent off of the full price and now we
just do algebra we could imagine there's
a one in front you know x is the same
thing as one x so one x minus zero point
three x is going to be equal to 0.7 x so
we get 0.7
x we could say .70 if you like same
number point or 0.7 x is equal to 1260.
and once you get used to these problems
you might just skip straight to this
step right here well you say hey seventy
percent of the full price
is equal to my sale price right i took
thirty percent off this is seventy
percent of the full price you might just
skip to this step once you get used to
these problems a little bit and now we
just have to solve for x divide both
sides by 0.7 so you get x is equal to 12
60 divided by 0.7
we could use a calculator but it's
always good to get a little bit of
practice dividing decimals so let's do
that so we get 0.7
goes into
12
60
let's multiply both of these numbers by
10 which is what we do when we move both
of their decimals one to the right
so the 0.7 becomes a 7. ignore that
right there the the 1260 becomes
126. put the decimal right there
the decimal right there and we're ready
to just do straight up long division so
this is now a 7 not a point seven so
seven goes into twelve one time one
times seven is seven
twelve minus seven is five
bring down the six
seven goes into 56 8 times
8 times 7 is 56
and then we have no remainder so it's 18
and there's nothing behind the decimal
point so it's 18 in our case 18 dollars
so x
is equal to
18
remember what x was x was the full price
of six avo six guavas x was the full
price of six did i say avocados x is the
full price of six guavas now the
question is how much will two guavas
cost me the full price
well this is
full
full price
of six so you immediately could figure
out what's the full price of one guava
you divide eighteen by six
so eighteen divided by six is three
dollars
that's three dollars per
guava
at
full
price
and they're asking us we want two guavas
so two guavas is gonna be two times
three dollars so this is going to be six
dollars
six dollars another way you could have
done it you could have just said hey six
at full price are going to cost me 18
2 is one-third of six so one-third of
eighteen dollars is six dollars so just
to give a quick review of what we did
we said the sale price on six guavas
12.60 that's 30 percent off the full
price or you could say this is seventy
percent of the full price
seventy percent of
the full
price
and so you could say thirty percent so
if you say x is the full price of six
guavas
you could say the full price of six
guavas minus thirty percent of the full
price of six guavas is equal to twelve
sixty and that's equivalent to saying
seventy percent of the full price is
twelve sixty you divided and we just
solved this algebraically divide both
sides by point seven and then we got x
the full price of six guavas is eighteen
dollars or that's three dollars per
guava or six dollars for two anyway
hopefully you found that helpful